cette semaine en ontario il ya des
centaines d'enfants qui ont été
suspendus de leur école dans la région
d'ottawa parce qu'ils n'étaient pas à
jour dans leurs vaccinations donc on
leur a demandé soit d'aller se faire
vacciner ou d'apporter leur carnet de
vaccination qui prouve qu'ils ont reçu
leur vaccin donc c'est vraiment la ligne
dure qui peut appliquer là bas on va
parler avec renault manuguerra gagné
dans sa chronique sciences de ce
mouvement antivaccin bonjour renshaw
parce que bon il faut dire que yann
baisse du taux de vaccination et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
s'inquiète de sa ouais c'est ça c'est un
problème qui a pris tellement d'ampleur
que ça a attiré l'attention de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
chaque année l'om est ce produit une
liste des 10 plus grandes menaces pour
la santé publique dans l'année à venir
et l'hébétude cette liste cela comporte
par exemple des grandes maladies comme
le vih ou et boladé des problèmes
environnementaux comme l'air qu'on
respire ou même la résistance aux
antibiotiques mais le tout ça c'est des
problèmes pour lesquels on n'a pas
encore de solution lorsqu'il frappe
cette année c'est que pour la première
fois on a ajouté à la liste le mouvement
antivaccin et contrairement aux autres
menaces c'est celui là c'est un problème
qui est totalement artificielle qui a
été magnifique tueur et par la
désinformation en ligne et selon l' oms
c'est un mouvement qui a pris de
l'ampleur au point où il met en péril
les progrès qui ont été faits au cours
du 20e siècle compte beaucoup de
maladies comme la rougeole la rubéole ou
la poliomyélite et vous mettez la faute
les études en tout cas de l' oms sur la
désinformation en ligne ce qui est quand
même des études qui donne raison à ce
mouvement antivaccin non les vaccins n'y
a pas d'étude qui ont donné raison au
mouvement antivaccin les vaccins sont
quelque chose qui sont très sécuritaires
c'est sûr que c'est pas un médicament
parfum iodé certains risques d'effets
secondaires mais ils sont ni niemi sont
extrêmement rares et les dangers ce
comparativement au lait aux effets
secondaires des maladies dont ces
vaccins ne nous protègent les maladies
sont beaucoup plus graves que les
risques des vaccins en tant que tel qui
eux sont pratiquement inexistants donc
on le sait l'absence de vaccination ça a
été liée à plusieurs épidémies ces
dernières années oui c'est ça les
vaccins en moyenne sa prothèse ça évite
deux à trois millions de décès chaque
année
cela évite aussi des dizaines de
millions d'hospitalisations ailleurs
dans le monde des progrès qui continuent
à être fait par exemple
l'om est satan éradique
la poliomyélite de l'afghanistan et du
pakistan au cours de 2010 neuf donc ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais on a aussi
vu le retour de certaines maladies qu'on
pensait pratiquement disparu par exemple
au cours des dernières années
la rougeole a fait un retour on a vu une
hausse de 30% des cas à travers le monde
et pourtant ces maladies pour laquelle
on a un très bon vaccin dont
l'efficacité qui frôle le 100 % en
europe il ya eu cinq mille cas de
rougeole en 2016 et leur 2018 on est
passé à 41 mille cas uniquement dans les
six premiers mois de l'année donc ça va
augmenter quand on aura les chiffres
pour la deuxième partie de l'année dans
l'état de new york aux états unis où ils
font face à leur plus grande épidémie de
rougeole depuis 1990 1967 quatre dans la
ville de new york en ce moment et dans
tout dans tous ces cas là les agoras en
occident tout cas les experts disent que
beaucoup de ces cas sont dus au fait que
les enfants ne sont pas vaccinés ah oui
c'est ça est ce qu'on sait pour quelles
raisons
justement le les vaccins sont en recul
au delà de la désinformation en ligne
c'est une chose s'essaye aux deux
grandes tendances d'abord on pense que
la vaccination certaines personnes en
fait tu penses que la vaccination est
pas nécessaire vu que les maladies
décalé nous protège sont devenues rares
où on omet mulele elle était devenue
rare un peu moins oui on oublier les
dangers que ces maladies là que
représente mais le problème c'est qu'on
vit dans un monde qui bouge beaucoup
donc même si ces maladies sont rares ici
ailleurs dans le monde a continué de
faire des preuves de causer problème et
à moins qu'on lit mines partout dans le
monde comme c'était le cas avec la
variole dans les années 70 et des bonnes
chances qu'elle peut que la maladie
reviennent donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
qu'une vaste majorité de la population
soit vaccinée pour que la l'immunité de
masse nous protège si jamais la maladie
reviennent et par exemple dans le cas de
la rougeole ont dit on a calculé qu'il
faut que 94% la population soit vaccinée
pour éviter que la maladie se répand
dans la population c'est reviennent
l'autre tendance bien sûr c'est les
craintes sur le contenu à l'intérieur
des vaccins même si c'est parmi les
produits médicaux les plus surveillés et
que des plusieurs dizaines d'études qui
ont montré que les vaccins étaient sans
danger
c'est une crainte qui restaient dans
l'imaginaire collectif par exemple il ya
ce mythe que le vaccin cause l'autisme
qui était qui est un concept qui dérive
d'une fausse étude de 1998 et qui a été
totalement discrédité depuis il ya aussi
la crainte de certaines composantes à
l'intérieur des vaccins mais tous les
produits qu'on retrouve à l'intérieur
sont nécessaires pour son bon
fonctionnement par exemple il ya
certaines molécules qui sont nécessaires
pour activer le système immunitaire pour
que le corps puisse apprendre à
combattre la maladie et tous ses
produits leur sont sécuritaires aux
doses auxquelles ils sont donnés donc un
mouvement antivaccin qui est l'une des
menaces les plus importantes les
régiments malheureusement maintenant de
la santé l'organisation merci beaucoup
renault fait plaisir à voir